[Musique]
moins de deux semaines avant son
lancement le festival de cannes vient de
dévoiler la composition de son jury
autour du président le réalisateur
américain spike lee on retrouvera
plusieurs français comme mélanie laurent
tahar rahim ou encore la présence
surprise de la chanteuse mylène farmer
tous participeront au choix de la
prochaine palme d'or pour cette soixante
quatorzième édition attendue du 6 au 17
juillet si je vous demande la peur en
gestes ou avec les yeux comme ça c'est
bien la colère la colère la joie
l'ambiance festive devra être supprimés
ce sont les mots de la présidente du
comité d'organisation des jo d'hiver
elle a dévoilé les nouvelles règles très
strictes pour les spectateurs en tribune
pas d'alcool pas d'embrassades pas
d'acclamations pas d'autographe
une fois à l'intérieur des stades les
spectateurs auront le droit d'applaudir
mais interdiction je cite d'exprimer son
soutien verbal d'agiter une serviette ou
de se livrer à une quelconque forme
d'acclamations
encore moins
et
oh
bien joué
[Applaudissements]
neo première réaction ça a marché
ah je sens que ma source distinction il
a dû manger ça y est ils comptent encore
et toujours comme ça n'est autre que oui
et au maximum de sa joie là encore plus
dur thierry mariani au second tour des
régionales en paca là
[Musique]
je sens des trucs sur moi c'était
violence évoluant j'en ai partout sur le
visage dans les cheveux ça plus à puberg
caca pipi endroit falette
la première équipe qu'on a décidé de
qualifier vraiment à l'unanimité parce
qu'on a eu c'est waou tous les trois
ensemble
[Musique]
les eaux du match du match
ça fait quoi le corbeau vraiment oui et
ça vous sentez moment solitude va ou pas
d'accord ok donc merci pour ce grand
moment
aux etats unis des images étranges oui
assez insolite à s'agit de dizaines de
vaches qui ont pris la fuite
california elles se sont échappés d'un
abattoir un portail qui avait été laissé
ouvert et des policiers ont été appelés
à la rescousse au beau milieu vous le
voyez d'une zone résidentielle qui du
coup a pris les déserts darren un petit
peu puis voilà c'est ça bon j'espère que
les vaches ont un chien à s'échapper au
final l'initiative a ému les internautes
amputé après avoir marché sur une mine
cet éléphant vient de recevoir une
prothèse fait sur mesure en thaïlande et
au cambodge plusieurs éléphants sont
ainsi suivis tout au long de leur
croissance
il faut en effet changer la prothèse
régulièrement jusqu'à leurs 20 ans pour
soutenir l'association wildlife alliance
les internautes sont invités à
sponsoriser un animal ou acheter des
oeuvres peintes de la trempe des
pensionnaires à partir de 100 euros la
toile alors que la saison de
reproduction bat son plein dans les arts
le monde des courses est en proie au
doute sont ils en train de créer des
armes et de chevaux consanguins c'est le
résultat en tout cas d'une étude publiée
dans le magazine scientifique report
la chercheuse et du blinoise du business
je crois qu'on dit et elle a étudié le
génome de plus de 10000 cursan anglais à
travers le monde
résultat 90 7% ses chevaux ont le même
ancêtre c'est lui northern dancer il est
né en 1961
vous faites des animaux ou la poule
[Rires]
je suis désolé d'être parti sur ce
terrain franchement je je je suis désolé
et encore à l'époque il ne pouvait faire
que 40 saillie parents aujourd'hui par
rémy saiss et voilà c'est à
l'augmentation assez l'acte de
reproduction et ben aujourd'hui en
moyenne par est annoncé 200 saillie ce
qui fait dire à l'étude que la situation
génétique depuis 15 ans en tire
dramatiquement va-t-on voir des choix
cinq membres ou a dit être ouvert
bientôt sur les hippodromes
mais la question reste entière ça me
plairait beaucoup
sans transition du tout il paraît qu'il
faut embrasser vos parents oui qui
s'appelle comment as tu as le droit de
le dire très bien sûr ben mes parents
ils s'appellent jacques et michel et ben
voilà on les a trouvés
depuis le temps pour les chercher eh ben
voilà bah merci surtout voilà alors ce
soir que je dis toujours l'objet d'un
slip demandez pas pourquoi
bah si je me demande pourquoi parce que
je porte un boxer mais porté à boxer
patate au fond du filet je voudrais
exactement après les chiffres adp
rapaces et les palourdes ça ça dépend
surtout ces sauvages parce qu'ils y sont
sauvages cnrc sont pas sauvages par
exemple
les anges moi je les ai jamais fait donc
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé à
l'intérieur
tout ce que je sais c'est que les
productions ne donne pas de drogue ça
c'est une certitude et ça je le sais
vraiment pas ce que je côtoie les
producteurs et que je sais leur façon de
faire je les coproductions peut-être
mais peut-être qu'ils arrivent à priori
oui mais comme dans tout métier
malheureusement c'est un ballon jean qui
directement dans l'eau dans l'eau aux
bénéfices il une fois que c coupé 406
grand est sont engouffrés là on va
l'écrire l'arrêt sans borne et son mur
dans l'étude dans les arrêts sont aussi
du coup tu n'es qu'un oeil sur les arts
ça veut dire que bah du coup les valeurs
ne sont pas encore tout à fait mûr mais
si tu les prendras la mer où l on et
centre juste quant à ma mère je sais pas
comment mais en tout cas c'est qu'elles
font mur donc du coup on part dans la
mer peut-être qu'il faut être beaucoup
plus vigilant ça peut-être mais dans
tout métier aujourd'hui vous avez des
gens malheureusement qui peuvent prendre
de la drogue qui peuvent boire de
l'alcool et c'est inacceptable dans tout
métier
la belgique c'est la bière avec un
mépris des valeurs et des bières
magnifique résumé la belgique a de la
bière dit non non non non mais c'est son
sosie saint geniez c'est bien ça non
mais oui cartes sur table on y est on y
est c'est ni couleur c'est à n'en pas
douter paraît bien ce que je vais pas
bon départ ne voit pas les fioles et moi
j'ai très bien de moi et je te comprends
ma foi
moi j'ai vu que travailler j'ai pas
abandonné j'étais clean pas longtemps
ils l'appellent vie non moi je disais en
plus en plus c'est quelque chose que tu
ne vois pas derrière ses breaks d'une
embolie n'envoie jamais français jean
soûlât du style m